[Música]
cuando yo era niño mi madre me llevaba a
ver los trenes
que fueron desapareciendo más allá al
norte de la y al este de la
sierra de los ajos
yo soñaba con que algún día me gustaría
dejar mi casa
viajar a todo el mundo y ver la vida
desde las alturas de las nubes como el
águila ve el mundo a continuidad
cuando más rápido corría más he visto y
he visto más y menos me di cuenta de la
diferencia entre personas y lugares
todavía hay amor aún hay miedo todavía
hay guerra
y a través de todo esto no hay que
perder la esperanza que es lo que me
hace regresar a ese lugar donde comencé
mi viaje
[Música]
sí
síntomas
muy mal y no hay un curandero
alma del alma
[Música]
pajaritos
a tierra
piedra o un río sierra
[Música]
y estas cosas son reales para mí
ellos me hablan yo estudio
[Música]
mi nombre está el valor durante
durante cinco años he desarrollado el
arte
siendo una persona independiente nos
llaman hacia los que no hemos pasado por
la academia a los que no hemos tenido
una formación artística en ninguna área
de lo que hemos conseguido del arte
esto me ha llevado desde el nacimiento
como cada uno de nosotros tenemos esa
capacidad como una cualidad innata que
tenemos todos los seres humanos para
desarrollarnos en un mundo aeróbico
nuestros primeros pasos
inician en el vientre materno
en los primeros tres meses de nuestro
desarrollo tenemos ya el oído medio
formado dos meses antes de nacer a los
siete meses tenemos nuestro oído
completo podemos ya escuchar la melodía
de la voz de nuestra madre podemos
escuchar
las palpitaciones del corazón como la
percusión podemos escuchar los
movimientos de nuestro vientre de
nuestro sistema digestivo podemos
escuchar
la respiración
incluyendo también la voz más externa
que es la voz de nuestros padres de
nuestros hermanos de la gente que gira
alrededor de nosotros
en ese momento entendí que
el arte era una cualidad
en un sistema orgánico que nos permitía
y desarrollarnos que nos permitía
integrarnos
esto me llevo a la conclusión de que al
nacer el niño ya tiene
el arte consigo mismo
hay otra actividad que es de energía
vital
que tenemos todos los seres humanos para
formar el carácter el carácter es la
capacidad que tenemos los seres humanos
para tomar decisiones ante esto
me di cuenta que la inhibición y la
separación en épocas antiguas en la
época medieval fueron fraccionadas las
actividades del arte
la música en un lado la escultura la
pintura la poesía la danza el teatro y
fuimos fraccionados ese proceso de
individuación
ese proceso
fue interrumpido y fraccionado
y uno de los aspectos más importantes
que nosotros poseemos para desinhibir
para encontrar ese camino de esa
cualidad innata que poseemos es el arte
porque eso nos va a permitir formar
nuestro carácter ser lo que somos y
decidir lo que queramos hacer
de esta forma este formato estas ideas
vienen desde nuestros orígenes
ese mecanismo
está integrado profundamente
en nuestro sistema y tenemos que
desarrollarlas tenemos que expresar lo
tenemos que sentir la seguridad de lo
que lo vamos a lograr y que vamos a
hacer lo que nosotros queramos ser
antes de continuar quisiera yo hacer un
ejercicio
voy a tomar mi guitarra
ah
había una frase que me empezó a
determinar no necesariamente que decía y
que dice
canto mi pintura y pinto mi canto
[Música]
la garganta es el 1er
organismo los músculos finales que ante
cualquier problema externo lo recibe
como un como un radar de temor con un
radar de
de alerta tenemos que estar siempre
pendientes porque es el primer contacto
también de comunicación con los demás
tenemos que recuperar nuestra
respiración abdominal
[Música]
no me veo muy bien así pero
tenemos dos fuentes que nos permiten
expresarnos y eso es lo que vamos a
lograr en este momento con dos vocales
con la a y la e
[Música]
ah
y para eso le voy a pedir por favor
[Música]
que me ayuden con esto y se paren por
favor
y que piensen en que en esa respiración
van a encontrar esa forma de conexión
esa forma divertida
con dos vocales
son sencillas
1 2 3
y
e
[Música]
ah
hey hey no te dejes engañar con un pan
con mermelada toca pipa de cacahuate nos
hace hablar no sabe a nada que esté
recatadas penas y te condena y te
condena que este reto a las arenas dice
condena y te condena
[Música]
no te dejes engañar con las mentiras con
la mentira de este gran como plantar
rosas no dicen nada no dice nada ya
saben que tu energía no es solo taco
tortilla que saben que tu energía no
sólo está por tortilla voy a la tienda
que te entienda no teman ea no de manera
toma la región que te entienda no de
manera no de manera
de esta manera
para tomar la renta
de manera
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]